live and I'll do the
intro I am Groot I am Groot I am Groot
uh what Benny means to say is welcome to
the weekly poll everybody uh in honor of
Guardians of the Galaxy we are talking
about Guardians of the Galaxy and uh I
think that since we've gotten some great
constructive criticism about Benny
interrupting everybody Benny has taken
the role of Groot from Planet X himself
and guardian of the galaxy so everything
that Benny says will be in his native
tongue that is to say groot's native
tongue and I uh will be playing the part
of Rocket Raccoon uh rocket and raccoon
not shown in video uh but I'll be
interpreting for Benny for as long as
this bit uh has legs so we'll see how
that goes I am s from TV little
house I am
Groot
you're
Star-Lord
yes and unfortunately you don't get hits
but apparently I'm Gamora yeah and
you're Gamora
Dave which means you're the most
dangerous woman in the Galaxy I have a
very deep voice for a
woman I would get very susp supicious of
me if I ran into me in a
bar I like that that's your that's your
that's your hook that's your intro what
was that scene from Crocodile Dundee
um oh yeah
okay yeah yeah yeah was very intolerant
but hilarious in
1987 I am
Groot uh Benny says try
harder I'm sorry
I'm
yeah it's right I'm gr he
remembers the
yeah
oh wasn't in 3D after
that I would have been happy about that
I'm not a huge fan of 3D like I I think
it's a gimmick you you pay an extra like
I'm I'm gonna jump out of
character hold on Benny no I'm gonna
jump out of character for a second
because yeah I am on perfect wait you
know you want to give me [__] Rob I'm
just going I'm just I'm just going to
say it all right learn how to do Skype
cuz no one can hear you
again you want to call me out for
interrupting you me and
Dave oh well of course I am Groot you
know yeah it was it wasn't a Skype
problem it was my microphone being
turned off an OBS problem I apologize
guys technical difficulties I am Groot
technical difficulties this has happened
before I I've been gone for like two
weeks and this is still the stuff no you
know what it was just don't worry about
me Dave I'm G yeah I'm G
yeah well he said it you know you you
get it yeah he's he said he's Gro I mean
that's really all that can be said at
this point that's
really um fun fact about Groot from
Guardians of the Galaxy uh the brother
of blackbolt Maximus the Mad who is in
fact mad but it's a genius hypothesized
that Groot is so smart that whenever he
talks all we can understand is that he
says I am
Groot yep I am Groot so the argument
here is that Benny is so smart
we're hinging our what he's saying that
we can't even understand what he's
saying that's the argument I am Groot he
is on a whole another level of
intelligence he says we're right I think
who knows why he he sticks it out with
us being so smart it's true yeah I don't
know um yeah Groot I have also heard
that uh groot's voice is the result of
like their their vocal cards are made of
like bark so like the sound that
vibrates against it only to us sounds
like I am Groot MH I I don't buy that I
like yeah Benny has heard that as well
so yeah I like the Maximus the Mad
Theory better yeah I prefer Maximus and
AD theories they're much cool do you
remember that awful Fantastic Four
cartoon from the Marvel action hour MH
where uh Maximus the Mad was played by
Mark Hamill that is the Maximus the mad
that I always think of I think of Mark
Hill's Maximus the mad I try not to
remember that that cartoon had a lot of
tight moments uh not the first season
where it was utter garbage I haven't
seen it oh
man was this this was in the 90s like 97
they were trying to capitalize on the
success of X-Men the Animated Series and
try to launch the Fantastic 4 Series and
it was awful it was so bad it was so bad
but you know what I actually Fantastic 4
Series being awful yeah it was like it
was so terrible I feel like season two
they kind of picked it up a little bit
wasn't wasn't the animation quality a
lot better than X-Men yeah yeah uh yeah
no it was in terms of like detail of the
artwork I felt like it was a lot better
season two got better but like season I
would jump up and down on my bed as a
kid when X-Men came on I was like yeah
X-Men and then Fantastic 4 would be on
and I was like oh I'm gonna be bored for
like half an hour yep y that's exactly
right I mean like I'm good
he uh crap what was it you know what the
if you ever want to know how bad the uh
the Fantastic 4 cartoon was check out um
if you YouTube flame on and Johnny Storm
you'll get the song that he sang that
the actor play Johnny Storm sang in the
show I must have memory blocks this show
must have been so horrible it's one of
the worst things I think I've ever seen
as a human
being I don't know man because I do not
remember that either like I like my
friends have done some pretty I myself
have done some pretty effing
uncomfortable things I've never cringed
harder than I have watching flame
on uh so if you've ever wanted to see
something truly cringeworthy check that
out it's something to behold um but no
seen season one of the office so yeah oh
the season one well which one the
British one of the American one the
American one but like M Michael Scott
just there were so many moments when I
was just like oh my God nothing beats
Scott's tots that was the most
comfortable I think I've ever been in my
life I I uh Benny never saw that episode
that was that
was I felt like I was on the border
breaking the law when I was watching
that episode yeah the FBI is gonna come
for me I swear to God I've never been
more uncomfortable than I am right now
oh my God I missed the office that show
it was awesome up until like season four
yeah and it was just yeah they tried to
stretch it too thin I think but I
thought that James sper came back and re
you know re like
reinvigorate crazy but thinking about
James Spader playing Ultron I'm like
yeah yeah and it's only because I think
about his experience in the office like
I know I've seen James pader over the
things but like all I can think of is
Ultron being on the office and being
like cool okay for California man yeah
exactly ridiculous okay so so with
Guardians of the Galaxy coming out like
of course Benny's done his whole
discussion with or yeah Ben's done his
whole discussion with Guardians of the
Galaxy and Guardians of the Galaxy month
and as far as I know we've covered the
full Gambit of all the Guardians of the
Galaxy characters at this point Benny
covered everybody and then both Benny
and myself covered Gro or Ron and the
accuser so we've got them all that
so so so my question is what are
people's thoughts about Gamora because
I'm curious about the way they're gonna
play her because I love the actress
that's playing Gamora although I can't
remember her name uh zo yeah
Zoe then he also knew the name of the
ACT zo salana man she ISO of course gets
wood for
Zo yes he dooot yes he does d what a
Zinger said Groot yes he
does this see this is why this is why I
love the internet because this movie is
gonna come out and by the end of the
weekend rule 34 is gonna be in full
effect oh my
God guarantee it man the internet is a
is a weird ass place it's it's such a
weird place but um like Zoe Saldana is a
really really good actress I thought she
was amazing at Star Trek and oh yeah she
was a great uh uhur yeah made you give a
[__] about who Aura was like oh that was
exactly the name I was gonna give to you
was Aura
really I always think remember that
scene in the bar when he's hitting on
her
yeah what about
it
ask yes I remember that scene just
flatlined my next joke oh I had a really
good solid follow-up joke you guys all
missed it I don't
[Laughter]
gr uh Benny feels really bad that that
didn't work out just in case you guys
are wondering I'm on drugs right
now the legal kind legal kind the legal
kind yes prescription I am
Groot and he doesn't want to have
anything to do with what's happening
right now I might be a little goofy for
for a couple episodes oh I don't think
anybody's going to mind it man it it'll
inject some uh it'll inject some weird
Dave which I think I think we need to
experience the weird side of day well to
a degree I don't want to experience like
the weird weird side of day just like
off camera Dave no don't don't don't
experience the the darkest deepest
depths of of my demonic soul my God man
okay if anyone wouldn't touch that with
a 10 foot pole God man this podcast is
taking a turn to forchan I don't know
what the hell is going on here like no
one knows what's going on in this
podcast right now we were talking about
Zoe Sana and how she's playing Gamora
okay so we were talking about Zoe helana
and in the comics Gamora is a very
formidable character like she's a very
very very strong character she's
actually a great strong female character
in the comics too and I'm curious to see
how they're going to play her out if
they're just going to like relegate her
to like a sidekick or like a love
interest of Peter Quill which I'd be
kind of disappointed with I just want to
see her like take her swords and just
like chop some people up I really really
hope they don't underutilize her she
like when they when they cast Salon I
was like she's not big enough like gamor
is supposed to be tall and Amazonian
it's almost like like if you like if you
want to cast a good Wonder Woman you
should cast like a good like that same
person as gamor because gorah is like
tall and formidable and like strong and
scary and like Zoe Sana is tough and has
weapons or has uh has action movie
training but like she ain't huge like
she's you know so I I hope that she
makes up for it I hope she like really
builds up the character because gamor I
hope they don't over sex her yeah I I
don't want her to be sexed at all like I
don't want her to be Benny agrees uh
there's no way like in the trailers
there were some love scenes though there
is a shot of like her kissing Peter
Quill I'm kind of hoping that that's a
misdirection like I hope that we're kind
of like expecting it to be that and then
it's she's like she she like pulls him
in she's like are you kidding like you
couldn't keep up like I would kill
you I had a sneeze stuck in my
nose like for a minute for a minute
there I was just like and I thought it
was G to come out and then it was like
it was like not today and then it just
like it went I
think I know I talk about my girlfriend
a lot but she doesn't like Comics at all
yeah and she's been liking Comics a
little bit more now that I've been
explaining some of like the more Dynamic
story lines they can have happen in the
different perspectives you can get from
all the different characters and things
yeah and and she's seen some stronger
women come up in the Marvel movies oh
tot she's she's really looking forward
to if there's a black widow
movie but I
think it would be appealing for her to
see a a strong female character in
Gamora yeah
just it really they they're they're
going to walk a F line I think with
making her an appealing strong female
character and not over
sexualizer because she's the type that
will take advantage from what I've read
and I've read a lot with gamorra in it
you know recently and she's the type
that would take advantage of a man and
like oh okay really overpower him and
like take control of him and then
threaten to kick his ass later like I
she's like
a impression of what that would be
[Laughter]
like but I I don't know I just I I find
it
challenging you know for them to to pull
off just walking that really fine line
that they do with Gamora as it is in the
comics oh yeah I mean that's that's
that's 100% right like Gamora is she's
brutal and Cutthroat so like like
whatever her particular goal is at that
particular point in time like kill
almost anybody to make sure that it gets
carried out and so you know I'm I'm
really interested to see how the whole
thing gets portrayed and and that's why
I'm curious because even with her run in
the Guardians of the Galaxy she had her
own thing going on like she had her own
separate events going on and and that
was that was that was really kind of
cool because there are some questions
that have to be asked here and I was
thinking about this while we were doing
the video on Ron and the accuser I don't
know what kind of face Benny just made
sometimes I think Benny just like like
he'll just like make faces he's trying
to get you yeah I don't I don't know
what it is just
like yeah but um but anyway um what was
really cool is yeah during the Guardians
of the Galaxy like during her run of the
comics like even then she was she had
her own thing going on and and when I
was doing Ron and the accuser and I was
talking about the annihilation Conquest
portion for Benny's Channel like the one
thing to keep in mind guys when it comes
to Annihilation and Annihilation
Conquest we talked about ronning the
accuser and he's like that much of the
event like he has a a four issue Series
in Annihilation he pretty much uh breaks
the Supreme intelligence is tank and and
that's his biggest role yeah I mean he
just kind of freaks out and yeah he's
there's so much more going on with
Annihilation like you have annihilist
who's just eradicating all life using
his Annihilation his Annihilation wave
like all the right little creatures and
monsters and stuff that are like
literally eating and destroying
everything but um it's it's really
really cool you know with her character
because during Annihilation Conquest she
becomes a select and she's part of the
failinks that's true and she is able to
get to um to make rich Richard Ryder one
of the select and that was really kind
of a cool thing but she still like she
plays on the previous uh you know
romances that Richard Ryder and her had
and she uses that as a way to more or
less like bring him in and and to I
guess like dup him into becoming one of
the selector I guess to be infected by
the failinks but yeah like you know her
character I think is really really cool
in the comics and I'm really interested
to see how they do it and I'm I'm with
Dave to a degree I don't want to see her
come along and just be like this woman
that's wearing like these super skimpy
outfits you know and and just me want
yeah exactly you know I don't want to I
don't want to see that man like I want
to see a character who's a strong female
character they can just wreck some [__]
like that's that's what I want to see
what's um who's the uh I can't remember
I'm blanking on the one of the
antagonists of the
movie uh nebula oh yeah we see a fight
between uh gamorra and nebula in the
trailer I really really hope that
like I have a lot of faith in James gun
and the movie that he's making and the
tone that he set I'm really hopeful that
gamorra kicks a lot more ass than just
nebula like I really really don't want
to see the action movie Trope of like
okay so the boys fight over here and
we've created this female bad guy that
the girl gets to fight like that is
something that I think we have outgrown
as a audience going public so I'm really
hopeful that gamor doesn't get to show
because I guarantee you that fight
between gamorra and nebula is gonna be
freaking awesome and totally badass but
I hope it's just one of many badass
moments that Gamora has in this book
Groot has something to say well I am
Groot but okay so I gotta talk I can't
do this I can't do this whole drop the
Groot thing all right so for the record
for the record there have been periods
where Groot has spoken if you go through
the comic series he initially was I am
Groot and then there was a period where
he was talking and like full bubbles oh
yeah I found out when I did my history
on them and then and then they just
thought it would be funny they brought
it back to I am Gro recently yeah so
like during the annihilation EV then he
talks yeah I feel like Bendis is
responsible for that for going back to I
am grp
IM Groot was originally the line that he
used when he was a monster from Planet X
right and then as they developed the
character he actually started talking
and he was like I am a higher species
and blah you know like crazy yeah and
they did that during the annihilation of
that and now they brought him back to
being I am Groot but I guess he says all
the I am a higher species things just I
am Groot yeah the uh the first time we
see Groot say I am Groot since
Annihilation wave is in New Avengers
when Luke and Jessica Jones are picking
a babysitter and Groot is one of the
candidates for that job and all he says
is I am Groot I I I think that that was
the ongoing joke from that point forward
I think so I think they were like stuck
it with and no one ever acknowledged
this guy used to talk like this and now
says I am Groot like yeah yeah you are
Groot and in every other Incarnation
like in cartoon in every cartoon form
and in this movie he only says I am
broot so according to like non-comics
readers and the movie going television
watching public that is all he does him
speaking normally would be confusing to
people now well exactly yeah because
they've now established that this is
what he does and I think in the movie
and in the comics they've pretty they've
pretty much established that rocket
runin understand him now yeah Scotty
young run now basically rocket can talk
to to Gro he's the only one exactly it's
like R2 and 3PO like you understand one
and the other one makes bells and
whistles exactly yeah that's exactly
what does are um but what I was jumping
in for was I do I think gamorra is only
going to fight nebula because that's her
sister as far as comic book stories go
right they have a lot they have a lot
going on and I think it'd be more than
just the girls fight over here but I
think that's what it's gonna boil down
to yeah I really hope like I think
that's true but I really hope that she
fights more I hope that Prison Break is
awesome oh because I want to see that
moment in Dan abnett's run from
guardian's volume like the first chunk
when she
burns like when she like turns off the
like she closes the doors to protect the
rest of them and like the first several
layers of her flesh get burned and she
like she just takes it and you're like
what a freaking badass like what a cool
moment like I want to see this like
fiercely loyal incredibly
powerful character represented yeah well
that's that's really what I thought
would be kind of interesting because
like the introduction of nebula I didn't
really even think about this until I was
reading more about the whole Guardians
of the Galaxy cast and everything that
going on but the introduction of nebula
I think I think it's really like them
again like saying at some point later on
down the line like we're going to reboot
the entire Marvel Cinematic Universe why
because Thanos is going to get the
Infinity Gauntlet and just kill
everybody so I mean oh you really think
they're going to reboot the Marvel
Cinematic Universe with thanos's with
The Infinity Gauntlet I think you
because remember in The Infinity
Gauntlet story line he wiped out half
life in the universe by snapping his
fingers yeah just to appease mistress
death just to make her happy like he
thought he thought that would make her
happy so um
I want to like I think that they may end
up doing something like that but even if
they don't like nebula took over The
Infinity Gauntlet yeah yeah like in the
second half of the story and then of
course Adam Warlock took it and was like
let this conflict end you know but yeah
nonetheless like I I love nebula's
character because she's a she's a space
pirate basically yeah and she's a really
really cool character in terms of like
what she does and she's very similar to
Gamora in that way like they're both
like really really brutal you know but
even then like nebula has close ties
with Thanos the that she you know
proclaimed to be his granddaughter which
was the reason why he made her into like
that Walking Corpse during theity
Gauntlet story line so that was extreme
that was man that was really really
messed up it it's brutal Thanos is a is
a is a you know yeah well of course at
the end of infinity I just finished that
like what they his son did to Thanos
yeah he encased him forever living death
like imagine just being frozen not being
able to move like that
isn't that what you're going through
right
[Laughter]
now right now Dave is in living death
yeah no um but what here's the funny
thing about the living death thing you
notice that no one else in the entirety
of the Marvel Universe seems to
acknowledge that that happened yeah
there people are like where is he like
where's Thanos and I'm like he's in the
freaking thing with the Black Swan yeah
like he was encased in like this copper
you know
orange whatever it is kind of right but
but no one else in the universe seems to
acknowledge it or that Thanos has a sun
running around ready to kill everyone is
that like a secret that the event is
that another freaking Illuminati secret
where they're like don't tell anybody
that Thanos is actually incased in
living wouldn't people want to know that
wouldn't that be a flag to plant to be
like hey guess what Thanos fell where
Earth what well in the Guardians of the
Galaxy book that you and I just went
over Z because you did it for your
channel I did it from mine um they
mention Json mentions to the galactic
Council Earth has defeated galactic
Thanos multiple times but no one says
they've currently got Thanos imprison no
yeah nobody and you know what's funny F
Json or Jason and the galactic Council
because Earth represent we have we're
the only ones who ever stopped galatis
from eating our planet and the only ones
who have beaten Thanos so you know he
said that he's like Earth is the only
place that has defeated Galactus
multiple times multiple times yeah and
that's that was like
one of my favorite moments from uh from
Hickman's run in the Fantastic 4 it's
actually one of the things that I love
love a whole lot it's it's the first
time the only time that you actually
ever see Galactus say that he's afraid
of Franklin Richards but um that's cool
like they're on some Planet I can't
remember what planet they're on but it's
uh Galactus Reed Richards and I think
that I think it was just Reed Richards
and Galactus together and
um Reed Richard they're they're saying I
can't remember what it is but anyway
Reed Richards is being sent back to the
Earth back to Earth by Galactus and
Galactus say says like uh he he says
something he's like he says he'll pursue
whoever it was that came after him or
whatever it was that happened cuz
apparently Galactus have been killed I
can't remember anyway he says uh he says
I hunger I need to feed and so he's just
going to like eat this planet and the
people are like no like you can't eat
our planet and so we Richards is like
well can you give us time to like get
him out of here and he was like you
don't have a whole lot of time but you
can do what you can because like I
really need to eat
right we I really got the munchies man
it I've been toking up all day I just
smoke a galactic size joint I am I'm
screwed you need to get these people off
I was smoking some Cosmic weed from
Planet X and it was
amazing maybe he ingested maybe he
ingested the weed like a brownie like he
went to ganja seven ate it and then he
was just like oh shoot I am this just
fresh in my mind uh I know I put it in
the chat but I don't know if you guys
were around maybe like it just got we've
been ignoring the last month or so Dave
but
we were trying to replace you with s but
didn't happen that that's part of like
the the group that that the creators are
in and all that yeah that are dressed up
a lot like the aliens from The Avengers
movie oh the Chui yeah the chitauri like
they had the little like squirr armor
thing going on oh are you talking about
the builders the build yeah the the
builders and the creators uh but they're
they're like a certain sect of that
they're like the dark something or the
the black black swans yeah uh POS the
black swans are the is the girl the the
the albino chick they have in the cell
next to parallel terax everybody at home
New Avengers yeah oh dude ever since
they when they first relaunched new
Avengers I immediately jumped on that
bandwagon I down for New
Avengers it's all about the Illuminati
it's not really the new Avengers in any
way she performed the new Avers say like
like yeah the story
the story is written such a way where
it's like like basically you just have
the Illuminati coming together they're
like hey guys this is what's been going
on and you just get like the backstory
explanations on everything and that's
what's really really what what I was
thinking while I while I was reading the
end of the event
is is Marvel really building toward
Infinity
Gauntlet or are they building toward
Infinity the uh the Cinematic Universe
you mean yes well they haven't
introduced the Inhumans yet yeah
although you know the Inhumans really
don't matter like oh you're so full of
that's could skip that why I say
that
is that event came out like almost
exactly at the same time as the Avengers
movie did like you could see them
putting together that end credit scene
with Thanos and
thinking like we're going to tie this
movie into this event
somehow yeah but see that to me that
would be a shaky plot because if you got
if you've got AOS has been really huge
ever since yeah but has been really huge
because exactly like he's the harbinger
like all he does is go around and kill
stuff that's like that's that's all he
does like all Thanos wants to do is make
Mr death happy so all he does is go from
like place to place ways to make himself
powerful and kill people like that's it
I I have no idea why he is so madly in
love with her right she's she's not
attentive she's really unsupportive of
him uh you know he could really do
better the analog for like the nerd
that's been
friendzoned well it it started it
started with his youth like it started
after he was banished from Titan and uh
when he was banished for a time he had
basically like traveled around the
cosmos and eventually came into contact
with mistress death so why do I keep
getting like beeps like messages in my
thing the Comics group is is oh oh you
got that beep on your thing I didn't
realize that I I'm what I've been trying
to resolve here is it looks like my
video went live but it's not live the
one that I was trying to get screened by
you guys first oh okay and I'm like is
it live because people leaving comments
and I'm like but it says it's not live
oh okay I was wondering what in the heck
those bleeps were that yeah what wait do
put yourself on D and D real quick me no
him because then it it mutes all the
noise oh cool yeah I'm not hearing any
beeps so it's yeah I'm not hearing any
beeps from your Audio Oh from my
audio well never mind don't worry about
it then so it's just coming through your
headphones okay that's that's fine as
long as it's not interfering with the
podcast I don't care but um so I'm sorry
guys I know I know I've been half here
but like I'm like what's going on why do
people even comment it's Al but like see
like like if Marvel came along like if
that's what they're leading up to with
the Cinematic Universe is they're doing
Infinity again it would be shaky because
basically you'd have the Avengers movie
you have a a teaser to Thanos you have
Avengers 2 which is Ultron and then
presumably you have Avengers 3 when
Thanos shows up and he says I'm here
because I have a son and I think he's
here like well okay then Thanos had a
kid that ran away and that's really why
he showed up to the planet Earth because
his kid ran away so it seems like it'd
be shaky and plus like I think the
Inhumans are are important because
remember Infinity kicks off the
inhumanity event because no bomb goes
off no nobody can even say what that is
like what like in humanity happened and
there like it's it's just that Meme
where it's like stop trying to make the
Inhumans happen it's not going to happen
like the in human this inhumanity thing
like look you got some great art I don't
care about your Inhumans I'm sorry and
and like like the oh no like blackbolt
set off the inhuman bomb and now
everybody like now all these Inhumans
are woken up and nobody and like it's
not carried over like the new Avers care
notic that the in itself hasn't really
been going on too much and the the
crossover event pretty much resolved
with him like in a month it was like oh
that's it that's it I think they were
like oh it didn't work okay uh
well that's because they did it wrong
like yeah they did it wrong like they
had a great foundation with infinity
like I thought Infinity was like an amaz
like one of my favorite absolute
favorite parts of infinity is when um
Thanos is confronting blackbolt you know
and he he's like where's my son and like
blackbolt like screams at him and so
Thanos just grabs his face and just
slams it into the ground you know he was
like take your secrets to the Grave or
something like that you know I was like
that's pretty badass oh yeah oh that
that that that book is full of awesome
black B like the amount of energy he can
like throw with his voice like it blew
up the whole entire city around them
yeah yeah it was it was he didn't even
Flinch that's what amazed me like I was
I was reading through that I was like is
blackbolt gonna scream and then like
blackbolt like screamed at
him because there's always that frame
where he does his face where he gets
like really angry yeah yeah yeah what I
love is how the ending though they
established that blackball did that on
purpose and freed the terog Genesis bomb
on purpose and everything was intended
to work this way yeah yeah and he pretty
much just used uh Thanos as an excuse to
do it so I kind of missed that what what
was the whole setup for the terog
Genesis
bomb Oh the the ter penesis bomb wasn't
like a bomb it wasn't like like an
atomic bomb this call the penesis bomb
because it released all the gases of the
ter like all the teragen Mist basically
into like the planet Earth and so
anybody that had late like because one
thing to keep in mind is remember like
when the Creed came to the planet Earth
the Inhumans that we had seen up until
Infinity were the only Inhumans that we
knew about but there were a lot of other
Inhumans on the planet Earth just nobody
knew about them and so when the terog
Genesis bomb went off all those
individuals that had inherent in human
genes or cre genes whatever it is
underwent penesis and changed into
whatever form they were supposed to to
change into when they underwent terog
Genesis so it's called the penesis bomb
just because it like like in the comic
panel like it physically looks like a
bomb like an atomic bomb exploded but
the whole I'm not I'm with Dave on this
I kind of thought it was an actual bomb
too like it was contained in a bomb and
the B like an atomic bomb a
bomb I thought it was just release I
thought it was like a rocket I don't
think it was no I thought it was like a
release I thought it was they called it
the penesis bomb but it was just the
release of the teren Miss right into the
atmosphere I guess they were just
happened they just happened to be
floating over was it like New
York when it happened that's that's
where the Inhumans like little island
thingy was yeah yeah which which the
record I just want to no no one said hey
this is a bad idea to leave the Inhumans
just floating over New York like that
yeah right because it works so well in
Oklahoma when we had Asgard floating
over
it is oh which is a fun okay so one of
the funny things that's one of the
things I loved when Thor come Thor came
back like Thor wakes up from the sleep
of the Gods whatever it is yeah when
they were just like oh well we got to
bring Thor back so Thor's just been
asleep this whole time guys he's just
been resting but uh anyway they brought
him back and he he's like he watch OD
sleep yeah like he walked in Oklahoma
and he was like Asgard and then Tony
Stark's like dude you can't do this and
he was like you made a clone of me in
Civil War and so he like I should kill
you for this and Tony star's like okay
you can have this and then
like way oh the uh the whole Thor in
Civil War yeah the clone of Thor that
you didn't know was a clone for like
three or four issues
dis a thoring what's going on why is he
such an evil prick yeah then you're like
oh he's a clone that's like robot or
something then he comes back and he's
such an evil prick here's now here's a
question Dave did you catch when the
actual Thor because Thor the actual Thor
did return during Civil War yeah yeah
did you catch that I I probably did it's
been a while since I've read Civil War
my God Dave I'm rereading it now for the
videos you got the entire Omnibus it's
4,000 Pages
surely I've got all the hard covers
that's even
bigger omn yeah Civil War was massive
man two months it took me to do that
series like I I was ready to be done by
the time Civil War was over oh I'm sure
but um but no during Civil War actually
during Fantastic 4 issue number such and
such I can't remember what it was but it
was when uh I think it was the the road
to Civil War when um the hammer of Thor
lands in Oklahoma and Thor shows up and
picks up the hammer takes the hammer yes
so oh that was when that was th's
official return was that like really
brief it was it was it was two comic
book panels or two comic book pages that
was it I'm not gonna lie haven't even
read Civil War
yet it's uh the the main story is really
hack need I know but every time I go by
the book it's like is thick and there's
like an Omnibus and there's like an read
the core story first and then skip front
line and uh just just watched Rob's
videos to the best of my ability front
lines is just a bunch of
action I thought like actually some of
the best stories in civil war came out
of Civil War front lines the the actual
intelligence of civil war is in
Frontline the only problem is Jenkins
and Miller clearly didn't share their
notes because like there are so many
inconsistencies the most notable of
which is that uh prison 42 MH Rec in
yeah well like no the the the Negative
Zone prison they yeah yeah
yeah in Paul Jenkinson's book looks like
wantan Mo Bay and in Miller's book looks
like a holiday in yeah and the the
emotional Crux of Frontline and why like
spider part of the oh wait wait wait s
I'm gonna help with this I'm gonna help
y maybe the back side's going to tal Bay
but the front side has a holiday in just
chilling from DUS till dawn looks like a
bar party in the front and business in
the front bar in the front vampire house
in the back exactly big ancient Aztec
Temple full of vampires in the back that
was one of the coolest parts of Dust to
Dawn that's the last seconds the last 30
it was actually the coolest part of from
did you know they're making a show from
dust Dawn no yeah TV show freaking like
like an fx show set in that universe
that's shared with The Quon Tarantino
Universe
what wow anyway why not okay I'm in like
I'm in yeah our next cross it's GNA be
all these crazy TV shows coming out
exactly but they missed the whole
vampire of craze yeah well you know what
I would rather watch the vampires of
from dust Dawn than any vampire that has
been invented up until uh Dracula the
untold story that's coming out in the
next couple months that oh God yeah
because I'm I'm sure that when Bram
Stoker wrote Dracula like Bram ster said
like years from now decades from now
Twilight will be made and this will be
the epitome of everything that I'm
creating here like oh my God no no no
I'm not watching the Dracula movie come
on a fist of bats H fist of bats here's
for the record I didn't see anything on
that that movie until I watched your
back issues and you guys mention that
and I'm like wait what's this
trailer I think we talk about Dracula
the untold story longer than we talk
about Guardians of the Galaxy yeah I'm
like what the f I go pull up the trailer
and I'm like what the hell that was
legitimately we were watching Hercules
we saw Hercules in the theater which by
the way is losing to Lucy which too bad
that sucks because Hercules was
ridiculous a that's thing to that Marvel
might might do black widow though I want
to see blackd movie I've got a side with
uh I got a side with s on this one like
Lucy was crap I want to see like here's
the thing I want to watch to get Lucy I
want I don't want to see you Lucy I know
what it's gonna
bearl Johansson that's all it is I just
like the whole movie the whole movie's
going through and like the I'm not okay
I liked Lucy real quick we're gonna take
a little side sidew here okay you saw
Lucy okay I did see Lucy I watched it
from beginning and I I actually liked
Lucy but the whole way through Lucy I
was like that's like this video game
that's like a Kira this that is like
this that's the Matrix now we're in The
Matrix now we're
it was like well that was fun but you
didn't do anything really original at
all and that's that's I love I love
sci-fi films like I love films that are
interesting and unique for example like
screamers all right screamers had this
really crappy low budet production but
dude but but screamers was about
machines in the sand that were killing
people and then started like producing
themselves and started like enhancing
themselves like I mean it's a really
lowbudget film it's it's not like don't
sit down watching it expecting for it to
be like an amazing Blockbuster film not
at all it was just a cheap crappy like
techn you know technological spin-off on
trimmers but nonetheless the film was
really really cool and I thought it was
pretty unique in the way the story was
told but Lucy is about a chick that
ingests a drug that can use more than
10% of her brain which is a ridiculous
fallacy in the first you Google that and
it's just and the show the movie's over
it's actually scientifically disproven
so many times you know what I'm not even
going to lie I I've never looked it up
I've always heard it through passing
that urban legend wheel only use 10% I'm
like oh that's a cool idea I never did
anything with it but there's a cavey
there is that how you say it Cav cave
caveat are you that drugged so so the
caveat there is we're only using certain
portions of our brain at any given time
but they're they're to do unique things
with our body or our dreams I mean I get
the whole orb leg that what I'm saying
is I wasn't aware that after get out of
it cuz we want to go see it because we
looked at Hercules on met on Rotten
Tomatoes and we looked at Lucy Lucy had
like an 83 and Hercules an 83 I had had
like a low school well I saw that it was
the day it came out so no it's down to
like 60 something right now like 61 or
something anyway so we got we went to
see because of that and I didn't know
the 10% I'm like that's a cool concept
and I and then we started looking at the
reviews and they're like oh the 10%
thing is [__] it's just to set the
movie up I'm like okay it's just to set
the movie Up what you that's the thing
but like if you're the the my issue is
is like you're you're spending like tens
of millions of dollars to make this
movie you got scarl Johansson you got
Luke basson great director love the
professional love fifth Elman he's gonna
do a great job except for Colombiana
that movie sucks and he is gonna like
make this movie about Scarlet Ranson
having superpowers and kicking ass I'm
in you've already sold a ticket problem
is you are trying to to tie it in with
pseudo science to make it make sense you
made The Fifth Element you don't need to
make it make sense yeah the drug just
has to make her just give her powers
well you know all it has to do the movie
is they don't even really play on the
10% what they they they set that up in
the beginning it does the first five
minutes is the whole thing we only use
10% of our brains and if we get to 20%
we'll be able to do this and if we get
the 30% we'll do this right after that
they don't really mention it too much
they use it as like a chapter marker
okay like she'll enter into a new room
and they'll be like 30% right and now
she can float people and like rip their
guns out of their hands you know then
they'll be like 50% now she knows that
you're thinking that kind of a thing
yeah and then beyond that they just kind
of close it up with now she's hit 100%
Akira mode you I mean like that's cool
like it like I want to see that movie
but I'm just sad that they couldn't come
up with anything clever but okay let me
ask you guys this because you all saw
Hercules is it any different from The
Originals Hercules must prove himself
and kill things no but there's the
there's there's differences here here's
the thing the the movie you saw the
trailer for isn't the movie like
Hercules the trailer is not the movie
you you're you're going to see
okay but that's what I don't want to
spoil I just thought of it as another
remake off of the original you know it's
a fantastic movie I mean it's it's John
Hurt is so funny
how over the top he is here's the thing
with with me and summer Blockbusters is
I have come to expect a summer
blockbuster action movie that does not
need to be anything else right Pacific
Rim was robots beating up monsters it
didn't need to be anything else for me
to go and see it and just be in awe of
all the visual effects and the
explosions and the giant robots like
getting smashed up yeah and you're right
and maybe that maybe that's why I like
Lucy because I went into basically
expecting Scarlett Johansson to start
getting superpowers and that's exactly
what happened I think it's because
Pacific Rim was like wasn't trying to be
anything other than what it was and it
embraced its own premise wholeheartedly
I feel like maybe people are liking Lucy
because Luke basson is a very similar
director to Gilma del Toro in that they
make very specific genre Centric
pictures with a very clear distinct
voice that's own like that's theirs um I
think that maybe the 10% thing probably
got played up because it is so wrong
like it's it's like well you know what
it's it's because it they mentioned at
the beginning and then it's not really
mentioned until the very end of the
movie where she's like oh I have all
this knowledge I have to download now
and that's pretty much it's the Aira
freaking syndrome outside of that they
really didn't use it and I think the
reason it got played up is because that
is the trailer right I mean uses 100% of
her brain and then they're
like I don't I don't know man I think
that was the way they went because it
was an easy way like it was it was an
easy way out come along to say well she
powers and she uses now she's able to
use 100% of her brain and she becomes
one with the universe you know and and
it's like okay like this is dumb it's
like powder on a universal scale like
this is interesting regardless of it
being the framing device of the movie
just to just to basically be the excuse
as to why she gradually gains more
Powers it's still the framing device
it's still where the movie is CED into
it 10% brain now she's going to get 100
she gets superpowers watch her levitate
20 dudes and throw them into a wall and
then yeah like unless she was able to do
like a car chase and calculate exactly
where to avoid car crashes so that other
people would crash but she would be okay
no I'm in like 17-year-old s would have
been like this movie is bad for film and
it damages The Human Experience and
everything about it is wrong and
terrible 31y old s was a hipster 17year
old
uh was very protective of the of movies
and had a very strong opinion about like
everything and now I'm kind of like I
have a strong opinion about things but
at the same time like when it comes to
what movies are trying I'm like like I
look at Lucy and I'm like man you know
like uh like it's it's probably cool
plus like whatever also you know a lot
of people made money to do that like
people need like all those all those
people had to work really hard to make
that like why would you it out of hand
just because I mean people really worked
hard on that movie like Dracula the
untold story like listen there were a
lot of effects animators working on that
film I don't know if you know this but
like you know give it a break man they
all need their job okay now now to wrap
this back up into being a comic boy
podcast right yes yes yes that is true
what you can basically do is a great
example is this Guardians of the Galaxy
movie 20 20 to 23y Old Benny would have
been like this is not the Guardians that
are the old school even I didn't read it
I went out and bought all the old Comics
because it's not like that it's just not
them you know but 30-year-old Benny's
like like you said they all need jobs
this is gonna be a fun ROM I'll
just that's why part of the reason why I
was worried about it to begin with is
like it was going to be released in the
summer and I know what a plague the
summer is on like artistic like
meaningful like awesome
quality movies yeah like normally the
winter time is when you go to see dramas
and like you know really epic like Harry
Potter and like Lord of the Rings and
The Hobbit and everything everything
that's epic and amazing in in film is
coming out in the winter time when
everybody wants to go on Christmas
vacation and see a movie yeah that's how
that's why James Cameron like I just got
these images of Dave sitting there going
I'm GNA watch The Notebook and then The
Hobbit
these really cerebral films that made a
lot to The Notebook oh my God that movie
was that movie was not even note it was
have anything it's like a it's called
The Notebook and it has nothing to do
with a notebook there's no notebook is
that is that that's your one takeaway
from that movie God damn it not even a
notebook where is the damn notebook The
Notebook sitting on a shelf in Walmart I
love that just I love that Rob's review
of The Notebook it's the poster and the
quote is show me it show me where's the
notebook so I do want to ask you guys
this though cuz we're all going to go in
we're all going to go see guardians of
galaxy tonight and if we arrange this
right we're not promising but Rob would
like to bring back the weekly Poll for
our 30 minute first impressions of the
movie If You Could Read Ethan and Ben
that would be awesome so we just have a
big family thing hey uh people people in
the chat like let us know if you guys
want to see that because I could
probably get Ben Ethan no only because
uh we're going to see it at nine: we'll
be back by midnight um the only reason
why Ethan's actually going with us is
because it's at 9: and not at midnight
um he's going to bed but you know uh not
old Ben it's old Ethan now well yeah
exactly Ben not working tomorrow so he's
like I could probably convince him to be
like hey man you want to jump on the
webcam and we could share it and like
get really close
and like no you want to cuddle here's my
cuddle and fall asleep together after
the movie Dave you're scaring me
[Laughter]
take you basically you did not say what
s's gonna say to Ben you basically just
looked at all three of us and just like
hey everybody you guys want to cuddle
you want to come by later Dave is losing
10% of his brain anchr he's taking pills
as we're Going's 30% what will happen
when he reaches
10 going
backward you guys totally my train I'm
trying to steer Us in the right
direction guys yes yes if I Rob goes on
same tangents and ends up talking about
Swamp Thing from the 1940s I don't know
yeah I'm glad I'm glad somebody's able
to real as sin because if that wasn't
there like if if there was nobody to
real as Sin God only knows what we'd be
talking about time the podcast we are so
basically Rob has discovered a
Kickstarter for the automatic robot
[__]
and I've seen that stupid robot we just
start browsing for for
ideas in super fast super slow romantic
evening I mean like clearly there's a
demand
no
uh I just I just thrw in that left field
so anyway okay so the question is with G
guys coming out we're all excited we're
all going to see it tonight how do you
guys feel about there being almost a
year almost until we get the next
chapter in the marble Cinema oh I am not
upset at all and the reason why I'm not
upset about that is because it gives me
so much time to do stuff like I'm going
to do Chris claremont's running the
X-Men I'm I'm going to I'm going to talk
about Chris claremont's running the
X-Men so William Striker um Jean Gray
dark Phoenix the Phoenix Force the
Hellfire PR you're not a YouTuber for a
minute Rob and you're not planning on
content okay
okay pretend you're just the nerd who
wants to watch movies we could tap into
all kinds of crazy Shield isn't Shield
coming back soon yeah Shield's coming
back soon so you got maintain interest
um that'll be the that'll be the only
source for a year of Marvel movies well
I've also heard that they're bring in
Hawkeye's girlfriend or wife they put in
some dang
superheroes no they're not going to do
it too much and it's like they're not
going to do it like the closest they get
is the centipede project and and death
lock and that's
basically no because the Netflix series
aren't starting up until 2015 are they
exactly yeah 2015 yeah now see I wonder
if they planned this on purpose because
we're GNA get a full Marvel Agents of
Shield Season yeah like 22 Episodes or
something or something well because last
time we got like 17 and then it crossed
into Captain America then there was a
big crossover and it crossed into th and
it was it was cool I liked it but I'm
kind of curious how we're going to do an
entire Marvel Agent of Shield cuz what
really hooked me on Marvel Agents of
Shield was that episode that tied into
Thor it was that episode that made me
start lot of people gay the crossover
episodes were the best episodes because
you were really pumped to see the movie
and you got like a little preview of
what was going on in the movies yeah let
me tell you something I know Thor the
epode like I was really into as shield
from the beginning I thought it was cool
I really liked that they stuck to their
guns they were like no superheroes no
capes it's just this it's about these
people these humans who are living in
the landscape of the Marvel Cinematic
that was really cool I like that um the
thing that the thing that blew my mind
which we talked about on I think the
show was the cre was seeing a cre I was
I was so going to say that my my
girlfriend we're sitting there together
I go no no they just did that yes I
really think that like if Guardians hits
we're gonna see more Galactic
involvement in Shield that's what that's
that's what I've been saying man like
that's that's what I've hold that train
of thought we are not we are not holding
our train of there's beway train you
need to hear these comments you need to
hear what our our viewers are saying
they don't care about what we're talking
about this entire conversation in the
chat is about Dave yes about Dave it's
all about Dave Dave is winning the
staring contest will Dave ever blink
find out a n podcast whole time save
whole Channel yeah also don't worry is
so cute I want to see Dave
talk Dave is winning the staring
contest it is pretty intense I got to
say they just going on about Dave and
then hermit man in in line with Dave was
like I watched The Notebook just so I
could see I could post Facebook comments
to make fun of all the serious scenes
every scene in The Notebook everybody
cares about Dave they do they
do um wow also really quick uh son
my channel because denish says that he
wants to see guardians but doesn't know
anything about it you should totally go
on over to the comic storian Channel
where I've covered every one of the
Guardians of the Galaxy and I'm about to
release the first comic book series and
we have a great Crossover with Rob and a
great Crossover with s and Dave didn't
show up for his
so nope Dave was too busy doing drugs
so all right you guys are saying I had
to like they're still going I had to let
them go with that yeah man just I just
man
I just let the chat do its thing Let It
Go I just love how apparently we're
boring but Dave is awesome yeah I love
that Dave is the only static image and
he's the most exciting part of the show
show he the most exciting oh man but let
talk about the show everyone goes to
sleep oh Dave's cool well at least we
got Dave but see here's here's the thing
so so basically they're gonna have wait
to follow up real quick to follow with
The Shield at Comic-Con the actor who
plays Coulson hinted that he was going
to be marll yeah he had actually talked
about that during an AMA he had hinted
at that he did an AMA on uh on Reddit
and they said if there was any superhero
you could play who would it be and he
said Captain Marvel so I'm in yeah I'm
down with yeah he'd be a great Captain
Mar do it yeah especially if they made
it a cool Co if the costume was
befitting of the show that would be a
great way to bring the cre and make him
studo
cre dipping like entirely into that
section of because if you bring the real
Captain Marvel down and you're like is
cre then you have to explain the cre in
full exactly but if Colon's learning
about the cre because that's what he's
now got blood in him we're learning it
that way that's a great way to go
through that see that's exactly what I
was going to say like with Guardians of
the Galaxy coming out I don't know how
they're going to explain it but Marvel's
got explaining to do because you got
Guardians of the Galaxy then all of a
sudden you've got Ron and the accuser
and people are like who the hell like
where what yeah and they're like well
he's a cre and so it's like well the
only thing we have about the cre is a
blue alien in a tank from you know
Agents of Shield so people which we
haven't even named yet we haven't even
said it's the yet yeah that's my
everyone's like oh no it is the cre it
is the I'm like it officially hasn't
what did they just say it's blue alien
five and C C named three alien species
one of which yeah Nam that we get we
know it's cre we're implying but we have
no official confirmation if it isn't cre
it's lame that's I mean I could be like
Rob's YouTuber but I have no evidence no
I'm sorry YouTuber but I have no
evidence of it no videos he's only got
videos but but nonetheless like like
they really need to explain that I have
a feeling that there's going to be too
much going on in Guardians of the Galaxy
to explain that and so I think that in
Agents of Shield they're going to touch
on the Guardians of the Galaxy Event and
then they're going to start explaining
the cre and it's all going to work its
way together where they're going to say
okay basically like you had Ronin the
accuser who really isn't a bad guy I
don't know why he's being portrayed as a
villain in this movie but anyway they're
like he's really isn't a bad guy he just
does stuff and he kills people with a
hammer and stuff like that
and bad
guy Marvel's doing a lot of this I mean
what's his name uh the man the Mandarin
he's he's not a bad guy he's just some
hippie remember oh my God okay I need to
I need to see Ronin is not like the
completely evil like dick of the
Guardians of the Galaxy movie yeah no
he's he's not he's not at all I mean the
the way Marvel does their giant Galactic
event events is everything's painted
gray like there's no real like good and
evil like like line that's defined for
any of the alien races until they're
actually an enemy of Earth yeah yeah and
there's an earth-based event revolving
around them in the larger universe
they're just living in the universe and
they have to stop whatever is going to
kill off the entire universe right Well
to Well to agree with Dave in the
infinity event the builders are finally
made off to be like really villainous
guys but they really weren't like that
bad before then they weren't just going
to go destroy Earth they just the
builders they they're also destroying
other like they took over like Infinity
they they like invaded every like the
shiar the everyone on the way to Earth
they're just like oh on the way there
let's just how many planets can be
controlled ex like that was like yeah
during like Infinity issues number uh
one and two and I think half of three
like they're just going from planet to
planet rting all life like Silver Surfer
shows up at the scroll home world when
it's in the process of being totally
obliterated you know and so it's like
it's it's it's cool when you see the
builders being portrayed but but I I
don't know see that's that's the thing
like with with Marvel like you can go
back and look at old Ron and the accuser
Comics you can go back and look at like
even the Avengers he appeared in three
or four issues of the Avengers you can
go back and look at uh Fantastic 4 where
he made a few appearances yep you can
definitely look at Captain Marvel Comics
because that's where he appears the most
and then you can look at Silver Surfer
comics where he appears a few times and
he just shows up and basically just like
executes the Judgment of the Supreme
intelligence that's really all he does
he just carries out the role of the
Supreme intelligence or carries out like
his will that's that's really the only
thing that he does but yeah you know and
I have a feeling that the way he's going
to be portrayed in this movie is he's
going to be a villain but I think then
we're going to learn that he's really
not necessarily a villain he's just
doing effectively like what he's being
told to do but I don't I don't know if
that's actually how it's going to play
out and I want to see him smash that
container with the Supreme intelligence
in it like he does in every single event
I've read so far you've got such a heart
on for seeing the Supreme intelligence
die I I really don't I want to see
something else from the Supreme
intelligence because basically all I've
seen so far the Supreme intelligence
says something that Ronin doesn't like
then Ronin smashes his container and
says no and then he goes off and does
his own thing I mean that's all you're
ever really gonna see like all you ever
see in the comic books when like the
relationship between the Supreme
intelligence and Ron and the accuser is
the Supreme intelligence says Ron and
come up here and so Ron's like okay
what's going on he's like I've decided
this needs to happen go do this and
Ronin says no and supreme intelligence
says yes and Ronin says [__] you and
then he smashes the tank I mean that's
pretty much the way it happens there at
least later on is he a leader or is he a
tool like what maybe the Supreme
intelligence is actually the face of boa
seem it would seem like Ronin would be
held accountable by somebody for doing
that yeah no he's R the accus he accuses
other people no great uh in Earth's
Mightiest Heroes he appears and it is
awesome yeah actually I haven't I I saw
that I saw a clip of that on I haven't
seen like the whole you got to watch the
whole show why haven't you watched it
yet you're such a bad Marvel guy no no I
mean I haven't seen the whole episode
Mar guy I haven't seen it's seen that
whole episode it's great he's he's
Unstoppable and
frustratingly you know himself like he's
he doesn't he's uncompromising yeah and
Marvel's like you can't stop him like
stop trying like it's stop just stop
stop it stop it you're embarrassing
yourselves you're so embarrassing just
stop it you can't stop him that was that
was scarily
convincing I'm sorry
Rob um all right well our commenters are
now talking about Shazam and The Rock
being Shazam I thought yeah hold on the
Rock is gonna play Billy Batson you
didn't know that no yeah there they're
saying he'd make a better Black Adam but
yeah he's been pretty much announced is
being and I think he'd be perfect cuz
he's got the rock eyebrow which is
pretty much Billy Batson's Cockiness you
know like I just saved Batman whenever
he appears he has that really cheesy
smile on his face and like a Pomp and
then he has like a twinkle on his tooth
when he
smiles like they'll make him that clean
looking yep that's the point it's so
funny be great Oh I thought you in real
life cuz every time I've seen the RO The
Rock in real life is going to plan no no
no no I mean like every time I've seen
the rock smile in real life like his
teeth like gleam sh like they sparkle
that may be
Photoshop I don't know man I've I've
I've heard that every time the Rock
Smiles a child's wish is granted I don't
know if that's true or not that's just
what I've heard so I want to believe I
want to believe um well we've talked
about Guardians should we talk a little
bit about other Marvel movies been
rumored no not rumored I was talking
about because they've asked us about it
and they said earlier would we talk
about it so I'm going to go move
there I what's his name Deadpool oh
Deadpool oh God I just looked over here
it's someone capitalized Daredevil so I
was about to go
Daredevil let's talk about wait a minute
oh Deadpool
yes Deadpool okay so so like let's let's
kick it off by saying everyone in the
chat everyone watching everyone who
might see this episode you've seen the
leaked deadpol okay okay there I I'll
give a little back story looked at all
up beforeand because we were debating it
right um okay so here's what we've got
we confirmed as many of these rumors as
possible there is leaked Deadpool
footage it is V voiced over by Ryan
Reynolds but it was made three years ago
as a potential pilot and the executives
at Fox at the time turned it down and
apparently it's been floating around
ever since then it was just everyone's
been watching it here and there and
there's even been comments of I'm
surprised this hasn't been leaked
earlier yeah now no one knows how it got
leaked or what's going on but Ryan
Reynolds is still technically attached
to the project he never actually left
the project never took off so no one
knows if he's still willing to do it
yeah but he's never officially said I'm
done with the project um with the
reaction to it Fox is cons is supposedly
considering the possibility of actually
making it um and uh I think there's only
really confirmed facts about it isn't it
because Ryan Reynolds has wanted it to
happen forever that's why he was in that
awful Wolverine movie and this pitch
this was like a proof of concept and it
was basically what it was yeah it's not
a teaser it's not a trick
no and people think it is and that's
what needs to be dispelled is like
people are like oh this has been
released that means that we're getting
it like next year no an idea that's been
sitting around you probably never get it
and even as I understand it's a proof of
concept that's all it is it's a proof
it's basically they made that to go if
we make a Deadpool movie This is the
entire this this is what we're doing
yeah and and as far as I understand
Marvel's been kicking around the idea of
how they're even going to rate the movie
if they're going to make it like rated R
if they're going to make it rated PG-13
in my person opinion if they're going to
make a Deadpool movie it needs to be RAR
if they're really going to do like
Deadpool cuz he's he's just like
arbitrarily killing people in like the
worst ways even like the jokes that he
makes are just outrageously
inappropriate so yep even in that even
in that teaser little thing that that
leaked footage the test footage he takes
a separate head and he's like puppet
yeah so so all right here so here's the
deal like Ryan Reynolds as far as I'm
concerned is it's probably like the only
person qualified to play Deadpool at
this point I like the guy who played him
in the the in the Hulk versus Wolverine
movie hold on hold on you gota consider
because that test footage we didn't see
Ryan Reynolds and Wade Wilson is [__]
beyond belief yeah so you don't we don't
need an actor he's not a pretty Bo he
just needs to be a stunt man and then we
Just Dub over him right we need a voice
yeah but what what I'm saying is like
like I think of Ryan Reynolds and I
think of like Van Wilder and Ryan
Reynolds from Van Wilder to me is
Deadpool just like the way he talks his
manism his fast it like that's where
else going with this only really needing
a voiceover if we're going to go with a
masked person why not Nolan North he
played Deadpool in that game yeah Nolan
North is great he did it he did it in
the cartoon as well and it's a okay now
you're just talking about like a person
to physically stand in for Deadpool no
no just a voice over well because the
test footage there's no Deadpool never
takes off his freaking mask that and if
he does it's scarred beyond belief and
what doesn't matter yeah yeah um I mean
Ryan Reynolds I think did a great job
with the voice over but if if we're just
need to voice over and Ryan Reynolds
steps down I think we have a lot of
possibilities yeah oh yeah there are a
lot of possibilities but I think Ryan
Reynolds needs to be the number one pick
to play dead I like Ryan Reynolds as he
I think well yeah I I like him to as
Deadpool and I think it'd be great
because he can also be the body guy you
know walk around and we could just scar
his face up lift the mask a little it it
would play very well but I'm just saying
because earlier C you said I thought
Ryan R stepped down from the project
yeah I did I thought I thought I'd heard
that around the same time that the
footage had leaked and that made me sad
because I was like oh like look at what
we could have had I thought that I
really thought that Brian Reynolds had
dropped out like this
week I can't find anything to prove that
no I can't either it could have been
that I misread one of the Articles yeah
um but I really feel like I read a I I
really thought I had read an article
that was like or read a headline that
was like Ryan Reynolds leaves Deadpool
finally like well if Fox isn't going to
do anything with Deadpool they just need
to sell him back to Marvel let Marvel
bring dead pool in because basically
he's a character that's just been
sitting around that no one's been doing
anything about well they don't know what
to do if they go back with Deadpool to
Marvel main he'll never show up no
because Marvel's trying not here's the
thing Marvel's not doing any R-rated
superhero things they're not they're not
pushing that that envelope I'm saying
like I think it'd be a fresh
introduction yeah well I know that fox
has been pushing an ex Force movie and
so that might be the next place you see
Deadpool I
mean uncanny X for sure I guess yeah
that's the plan is it would be like a
covert Black Op I don't know if I can
handle like multiple X-Men movies per
year though I'm done with X-Men movies
like we saw D future P was awesome fun
great end it let's move on yeah let's
let's do something else they're just
going to give the rights to X-Men back
to Marvel I think last time we talked
you said Marvel said they're not going
to uh do anything with X-Men even if
they got him back but uh no I think it's
like spite is what they're pretty much
doing with it now yeah okay I'm reading
an article that just came out four hours
ago that basically says that due to the
reaction of the test footage it has now
been tweeted out by the original writer
of the script that they have now
modified a PG-13 version of the Deadpool
script oh man I don't want to see a
PG-13 Deadpool I want to see a rated R
Deadpool chopping people's heads off
yeah and making just wildly
inappropriate jokes like that's how many
heads can you chop off in a PG-13 movie
yeah what's the limit you know there's
you know they have that written down you
know there is number 19 heads if you do
20 it's our look at look at Lord of the
Rings Aragorn I think shops at least
three do a decapitation
counter oh somebody will during the
movie oh yeah if that movie comes out
somebody will like somebody will do a
counter on dead pool in front of a
camera in a dimly lit room like sweeping
back and forth saying all right we can
chop off 19 heads in this movie same guy
has tweeted out say the f word two times
Wolverine impales people with his claws
on film all the time and he withdraws
with no blood for great flavor and
success the difference between an r and
a PG-13 movie it's true it's really is
just blood blood F bombs and and and
boobs and boobs yeah true you can't say
the f word twice I want
boobs I want to see Deadpool's boobs um
oh that's Lady Deadpool at least get
your Deadpool right they actually have
like what really bothers me is they
actually have like a limit for every
single swear word yep and like every
single like violent act that you can
have in a PG-13 movie so like literally
at at this point somebody could make a
movie that literally pushes the limit
all of the way yep to the line and then
just stops and it's still PG-13 yeah
it's still a lot of stuff that's going
on in that movie that's wrong yeah but
I'd be curious to see how they do it
because one thing to keep in mind is
that with Deadpool with Deadpool comics
either he's fighting just random bad
guys or he's part of a major storyline
right so I think I think right now he's
fighting
Dracula well yeah but I'm saying like
like if you go back and yeah like if you
go back and look at like his older
Comics I mean I guess you could
introduce like evil Deadpool but then
that have to be rated R but um you know
like for the most part you've got the
original Deadpool with toer and cable
and all those guys you've got cable and
Deadpool you've got uh Deadpool kills
the Marvel universe that would be it um
MC with a mouth man I cannot wait here
in this one he's fighting Disco vampires
okay while trying to rescue his own
daughter I mean his his character was
never designed to be taken seriously
well at least it wasn't you know when it
finally went over well the new writers
are trying to put a spirit serious spin
on because what they did was they opened
the story lines with uh the presidents
came back as zombies he had to go kill
them but because he did that for shield
because they couldn't have Captain
America on the news killing you know
Benjamin Franklin that was their excuse
Deadpool became like their go-to
Waterworks guy um he got sent to Korea
with Captain America and Wolverine to
fight against Deadpool clones who were
being merged with other superhero Powers
yeah um so there was a whole plot where
you discovered that they had actually
gotten his jeans from his wife and his
daughter they were still alive he had to
go save them then the wife was dead he
then was coping with that for a while
like he had a wife and lost her before
he even got to know her yeah yeah
Mercedes whatever her name was but right
and then and then he thought he lost the
daughter now the current storyline is
the his friend overshield has treed
because of original sin where his his
daughter's alive and where she is yeah
yeah but what I'm saying is that deadpol
there's an amazing line here no he's not
and even with his serious storyline
that's what I was going to say um
there's an amazing line in here where he
goes uh like he he grabs his daughter
and he hasn't said who she is yet like
that I'm your dad yeah and he's trying
to save her from the bad guys and he
runs into an elevator and he's like I
know you must have a million questions
and I'll try to answer them all go ahead
and she's like are you my weird dad is
my mom no more questions right now yeah
yeah I saw that panel and that's
Deadpool that you know that yeah exactly
and and that's that's the Deadpool I
hope they bring because the best part of
Deadpool is the fact that he's just not
a serious character and he ejects like
he he injects silliness into serious
storylines like like again I I touch on
it all the time but one of my favorite
Parts is when uncanny xforce goes into
the future to find Strife to fight
strife and Deadpool is in the future and
he's been sitting in a room for 600
years and so like he runs into to wolver
rain in them and they're like what the
hell are you doing here and then he just
immediately just starts running off of
his mouth again and just starts going
like making a whole bunch of nonsense
like that's what I love the most about
his character oh look I just lightened
up my room I I I just saw the thing I'm
green why did nobody tell me I'm green
this whole it it just it just turned
green hour 15 minutes I've been green
and no one bothered to tell me that
thank by the way that Zoom thing isn't
fixed either don't make me
mad but I don't I don't know I mean you
know to me Deadpool is one of these
characters where you have to
have oh my
God Benny are you gonna be okay I'm
sunburned and and Gamma radiated what do
you want from
me but um he needs to be a character
that's done in such a way to where it's
they do it right like they do him in a
way where they're able to maintain the
funny elements of his character and the
fact that he can inject humor into a
serious circumstance because he's just
he's just out there and crazy like the
whole first person monologue that he
thinks is an inner monologue you know
like those things are hilarious those
are those are what are really funny so
yeah you know those are things that I
want to see in the film I I think that
Marvel needs to embrace the Bruce Tim DC
format from 10 15 years ago and just say
like if you want to see a more
like definitive version of your
characters check out this directed DVD
animated movie done by this really great
Studio yeah like if you want to see a
Deadpool on in a movie I think like if
you got like call a Deadpool series
let's say they put out a Deadpool movie
every other year and it's a Deadpool
movie that's said in the Marvel Universe
because animated they could do whoever
they want whatever they want they could
adapt Deadpool kills the mobile Universe
they could adapt any dead that would be
amazing if that came out like every two
years I think people would be I think
comic fans would be more okay with a
PG-13 Deadpool live action movie because
they're like you know what they can't do
everything and it's owned by Fox so you
can't even do Marvel character
characters you can always do X-Men and
how many actors from the X-Men movies
are even going to come back to do this
Deadpool movie so they really are
limited by that like Studio control but
if I want to see Deadpool cutting wise
and H like Cutting Loose and cracking
wise and having a great time and and
being and
moving I'll just pick up this DVD
because it's really awesome like that's
what they should be doing well and I
100% agree because they put him into so
much crap he was an Ultimate Spider-Man
great role they worked him in he was he
was he's in the movie I think it's like
Hulk versus Wolverine cracking jokes
cutting best scene in that is him trying
to put his limbs back on no no that's
not right I never expected the caveat
with that though is Marvel still has
their own rights for animated X-Men yeah
they could fo has no rights for
that why isn't Marvel doing that CU
they're doing all of these experimental
films they're doing motion Comics
they're doing Avengers Confidential
they're doing the anime spin did anyone
watch the anime I don't know about you
guys but I hate motion comics oh I love
okay so give us a real video give us a
real movie there's plenty of Deadpool
stories that would make a great could
you imagine a Deadpool movie done by
Disney
Pixar oh my gosh well Disney Pixar is
doing Big Hero 6 and they're totally
screwing that so even if how can you
screw big hero six isn't it kind of
crappy anyway I mean it is man but it's
that's like scre it's an all Japanese
superhero team yes6 was okay so if it
was version is I would watch a a
Deadpool movie done by
Pixar okay like imagine like Marvel
babies you know what that would happen
if they did that at one point Deadpool
would cut across all the toys from Toy
Story just slice them all in half ex he
would like off of a car and then that's
exactly what would happen in his head in
his head the car would be talking to
him yeah the car well you know there's a
Pixar verse too yep yeah that's what I
mean like he'd be in the Pixar verse
yeah he he would he would get teleported
somehow to the pixars and like kill enti
pix the Pixar verse right now here's a
uh here's a pitch by the way just a
really quick because of the Disney
Marvel like merger and everything that
we that happened three years ago and why
we're still talking about it but um
there's not much else happens man yeah
let me let me Pitch Let Me Pitch this
game uh Kingdom Hearts Deadpool not not
like a game about Deadpool just one of
the characters you get to play with is
Deadpool and then Deadpool is your
gateway into all these different and
just seeing Deadpool's reaction to like
you know the Aladdin Universe you know
what would happen you know what would
happen if Deadpool it would be a blood
bath you would have Mickey
Mouse Mickey Mouse would kill with one
of the keyblades or whatever it is and
then Deadpool would just kill him yeah I
mean like and Deadpool's reaction to the
Final Fantasy Universe I think that'd be
great I think this is a fan fiction that
s needs to write I don't I think it is
Deadpool meets Kingdom Hearts yeah I
don't while you're it while you're at it
I want cloud and aith to finally make
love
son I want them to finally bump the
nasties yeah but um but I don't know I
mean at the very least you know I'm glad
to see the fox is now considering the
idea of actually making the movie
instead of just throwing on the back
burner and every once in a while saying
hey how would you guys feel about the
movie and then I think when this kind of
stuff gets leaked it's actually by the
people yep at at Fox or at at Disney who
are just like let's see how the internet
reacts to this well know that and then
they put it out there yeah that seems to
be Warner Brother start I'll bring that
up in a minute just keep going guys just
finish Warner Brothers strategy seems to
be leak the pilot see what they say uh I
don't think that fox did intend to leak
the Deadpool pitch but I know that once
they saw the reaction they officially
released the HD oh yeah cuz it was on a
phone camera and then they they
officially said here is the Blu-ray H
1080 HD version of it yeah and they were
I mean like and you saw when that when
that I remember when that first launched
I think like well when we first heard
more about it and I think they they it
happened at San Diego yeah and I want to
say that like um when that first hit the
internet as far as like we are I mean
like I know it's been around for three
years but the reality is no one's been
talking about it for three years it must
have like really leaked at San Diego
ComiCon Fox took real effort to get that
[__] down to take that down everywhere
everywhere you saw it they were like get
it down get it off as opposed to
Constantine pilot which you could still
watch at any point because it's still
there thanks to Warner Brothers
releasing it uh but once Fox saw the
reaction to the Deadpool teaser or the
Deadpool proof of concept I think they
were like oh [__] like we can actually
do something with this oh yeah yeah we
could probably sell this freaking thing
like well they they probably it's
probably why that guy started tweeting
out that he he had to revise they
probably immediately said hey are you
still interested in that script we need
you to tone it down to a PG-13 rating
you know they called them and they said
all right well I guess it's back on I
mean but but well I mean I mean that
doesn't mean it's back on that just
means they've cleaned the script up back
on like pre-production is back on I mean
like right into the mouth of madness has
been pre-production for the past like 10
15 years yeah you know but I me one of
his tweets says it probably be about 5
years before we see that thing actually
come to fruition so yeah that's like
like good luck finding my interest in
five years that's like Amazing
Spider-Man 3 is going to come out in
2016 yeah have fun you know I don't I
don't care if Amazing Spider-Man comes
out in 2016 man that movie was I hope it
never comes out I don't want to see
anymore I want them to shut it down and
just let Marvel do the
let I'm saying this right now this is my
claim on this if we do get Marvel
because there's been talks about them
just saying [__] it here it is just have
it back pay us CU apparently Disney has
offered them and they keep saying no
because they think they can do more
money with it yeah so there's been talk
supposedly I don't know if it's rumor or
not about them finally saying just take
it back we're done I would love um and
if that happens I don't want to see
Marvel origin story him do the stories
we've seen I just want to see Spider-Man
swing into a movie be like I made it
here I think Marvel knows I think Marvel
knows better than to do to their fan
base they just need to show what they
would do just ignore what happened in
those other two movies and just
here's Spider-Man and he's and he's
already been Spider-Man for a while and
the heroes are just like what why
haven't we brought him up because he's
annoying like yeah exactly yeah all she
have to do is simply be like did you
guys hear about that Spider-Man guy oh
man I went with him last week and he
just cracked jokes about hot dogs the
whole time exactly he the window and
he's like Tony yeah don't ever don't
ever team up with Spider-Man he will
never stop oh okay okay so so speaking
of Spider-Man I want to break off from
this for a second and I want to talk
about the most recent original sin
release we jumping over to another topic
the question that the guy asked um star
kid Potter wanted to know why do we
never discuss anything outside of the
Marvel DC his particular choice was
fables I don't read fables that's
neither I've been wanting to read fables
like I've seen it on the Shelf at the
comic book store and I'm like I want to
get it but it's $30 and there's other
things I want for $30 yeah I like I
never end up picking it up but I I would
love to read it I I read some indie
stuff I know I haven't talked about it
very much but I do read yeah we could
probably talk about Saga I mean yeah I
actually don't haven't read fables in a
while um what actually reinter
interested me into fables was the fact
that once upon a time which I thought
was going to be a very girly show but I
was sitting around on Netflix one night
and I was like all right whatever just
hit play see what this is and I was like
this is freaking amazing and I looked in
line I was like this is supposed to be
fables like they just took the whole
thing and just ripped it off like okay
that's exactly what they did I I me I
hav't read too much fables I mean I am a
fan of it to an extent but I only have
so much money to spend per month and
right now my my money is like dumped
into DC and Marvel um and Saga and
Walking Dead like I've already got my
Indies kind of picked out um trees is
another one thanks to actually a off the
rack from sou I actually started picking
up trees trees is cool yeah trees is
cool yeah I mean there's if people want
to see more stuff besides model DC I
mean there's Dark Horse there's a
million things that we could tell like
a channel I'm just plug myself here for
a second here um but my comic book star
a Jason he actually reads all the Indie
stuff Darkhorse image all that stuff he
does all that like stuff that we don't
normally read um so I'm starting to do a
Jason off the hip where he discusses all
that he has I've got a a six minute
thing where he discusses the future of
Star Wars comics um and this week he was
talking about uh the Divine and
wonderful or the the demon and divine
the one where the gods have come back is
pop stars yeah oh God that is crazy that
is I'm starting to dip into that myself
but uh I don't think anyone here is an
expert in Indies like that's our biggest
isue I'm not I can tell I can tell you
DC's history from the 1940s and Robin
and S probably tell you Marvel's history
from the 1940s so I could probably tell
you both of them honestly I could do
both I well not maybe not both but I
could definitely do Marvel DC I could
give you the origin of the max or spawn
yeah I mean I could Walking Dead but
when it comes to the branching into
Indie titles fables Saga um it's it's
not I think the biggest problem with
Indies and the reason why we can tell
you so much about Marvel and DC is
they're so intered woven yeah you you'll
start reading one thing in DC and then
it'll jump to another Super here in
another part of the element of the
universe and you'll just keep going and
you'll end up circling back around but
when you wor Saga you got wait for the
next Saga there's nothing Tak forever
and it's and like yeah and it's hard to
speculate on that book too it's hard to
be like oh what's gonna happen in Saga
like I don't [__] know it's my M came
on I know whatever I say is not right I
know there's only one Indie that I
collect and that's the Grims fairy tales
because they always do the naked covers
of the cons and they're worth like a
small fortune so I got pick those up you
go to a con they like it's $100 and you
go look at eBay it's like it's 400 here
I guess 13 real boys love topless girls
on their cover let me buy that just like
how like how can you enjoy that like you
can't even put it out like you know your
parents are just going to take it away
from you that's I don't understand about
like I pick them up and you know what
happens because I feel I mean I'm I'm
All an older guy I feel awkward having
the topless girl of Grims that goes like
in a bag and board black bag and thrown
in the Box put between two other Comics
man know I've got a topless Mermaid
cover here I'm not the audience probably
doesn't have much faith in this at this
point I don't blame him but at one point
on my channel I am going to start doing
Indie stuff awesome fables is one of the
books that I want to look at eventually
fables is Good from seen and I do
recommend if you have the money to spare
on it I do yeah so like there's a lot of
nice hard covers too like you see those
hard covers on the Shelf they look real
nice like they're really nice they're
really organized They're All
Uniform uh I really want to get into it
but I I just haven't yet I've I've got
spawn and I've got I've got the first
volume of saga that I haven't even
gotten the chance to read yeah Saga is
really good I I think Saga is probably
one of my favorites right now uh John
just mentioned another one that I know
you know something about s why the last
man yeah oh yeah that's really good too
why is a good book I mean it's all like
it's done but we could still talk about
it I mean you know like like The Walking
Dead is really one of the only Indie
Indie titles that I read Because The
Walking Dead is amazing The Walking Dead
has gone to [__] ever since they did the
time Jump well see I haven't gotten like
I haven't I I need to get caught like I
haven't gotten
okay Kirkman seems to have run out of
ideas so he was like we're just going to
jump ahead like two to five years
something maybe this will jog my
creativity and it's not it's doing
horrible we just time jumped ahead the
time Skip and it's oh okay I don't like
it see like I I stopped to the point
where Rick came across well we're not
well never mind we're not going to spoil
in the series yeah let's let's talk
about Marvel DC and then out of nowhere
spoil Walking Dead spoil The Walking
Dead okay so anyway so anyway getting
it's like a trojan horse like hey what I
what I will say this is this guys like
for those of you that are not familiar
with The Walking Dead comics but are
watching the TV show it only gets better
yeah like it's it's going to get really
really really good well the comics TV
show the TV show he does in is a
different direction it's the direction
that he has stated he after rethinking
the comics where he would have liked to
have taken it yeah well the the thing
now is like I mean to to stay on this
for a second or two um in the TV show
they're just now coming across the
cannibals but in the comics they had
come across the cannibals a long time
ago and it was only Rick like he was the
only one that came across they almost
killed him and ate him so uh you know
it's and Rick's gone through a few other
changes too at this point like there's
especially like a major change with Rick
in terms of like his his physical
capabilities you know in the comics but
nonetheless um I wanted to touch on the
most recent release of original sin
because I actually really enjoyed the
way they had gone with that what are you
what are you doing s are you talking to
oh my girlfriend's leaving the house so
I wanted to say goodbye oh dude have
your girlfriend say hey to everybody
okay Tiffy come here oh it's it's the
girl from the bonus rounds oh my God hey
it's Tiffany from bonus
round hi
Tiffany I'm gonna go and yell at the
AT&T store so I'll see you guys later
see you later oh boy but um but anyway
like I really like the release of what
they did like with the new original sin
like the things that they talked about
and what they did and the whole reason
why I like this is because they finally
explained why Nick Fury just doesn't
appear yeah like you major story lines I
mean we know with with civil war secret
that uh that Nick free Was preparing for
secret Invasion like he was figuring out
the Scrolls invading the planet Earth
what is that the one that came out
yesterday the one that came out last
week I haven't got the one that came out
yesterday there's another one what did I
miss wait there's another original sin
did it come
out I don't I don't know I thought I
don't recognize he's talking about with
the whole Nick Fury thing I read last
issue I thought no no the one that came
out it's issue number six I think the
one that came out they Nick Fury was
talking about his role in the Marvel
Universe and that the stuff that they
had come across where like all these
creatures have been killed and like a
whole planet was killed and stuff like
that Nick Fury was the one doing that
that of all the conflicts that we saw in
the Marvel Universe like the cre the
Scrolls stuff like that like those yeah
like those were the only ones that were
able to get through that there were so
many more times when alien races that we
never even heard of had potentially
tried to invade the planet Earth but
were destroyed by Nick Fury so like he's
he's in effect like I sense a comic
series that's what I'm saying I would I
dude I would love that but that's that's
what they were saying they were saying
that like they were saying that like
from the time of like basically like
World War II from the time that Nick
Fury appeared in World War II and when
he became the director of Shield uh
during the uh his run and uh Strange
Tales tal of Spence whatever it was that
from that point forward they were all
life model decoys and that the actual
Nick Fury was traveling around and was
like destroying threats to the planet
Earth and that's what I loved about that
because you never they never explain
that like you would just have some
really cool storyline like like Schism
in X-Men and like Nick Fury is nowhere
to be seen and it's like you know Nick
Fury is like the source like the person
that all the superheroes go to if they
need information that they simply just
don't have because if nobody if no one
else knows what's going on like Nick
Fury knows so yeah I love the fact that
they've explained all that that should
be what the comic series is called Nick
Fury knows Nick Fury knows that's that's
what I loved because now like Nick Fury
is old like the infinity formula's worn
off you know he's aging at a super rapid
rate and so the comic book came to a
close when Nick Fury said that he wants
somebody to take his place I personally
think it's going to be frank Hassel and
they're just going to write Punisher out
of the comics that would be so smart I
would to finally give him a role would
be amazing something to do you spin off
another series exactly but here's the
problem with doing that you'd have the
Punisher in charge of quietly removing
threats I
mean giant explosions happening
I guess Frank Castle's busy up there I
mean I mean Frank Castle is the guy that
comes across villain and kills them no
questions asked so I mean do you really
want that guy making sure the planet
stays safe but it'd be the perfect role
for him if he were somehow able to move
away from being like insane yeah well I
mean he I mean you have to be insane a
little bit to do what Nick Fury does and
so I think like it works like we like
being uh military trained being um
having a man with a mission I mean like
the only thing that the only issue I see
with the Frank Castle taking over the
job is like Nick F has an inherent deep
connection with Slash uh love SL uh like
you know parental view of humanity like
he has a deep inherent need to protect
the people whereas The Punisher is just
murdering people because his parents are
dead or because his family's dead I just
went Batman for a minute but evil Batman
um doesn't Batman fight The Punisher at
one point off panel in like half half a
second it's amazing um oh in Avengers
JLA like Batman sees him break into a
drug ring and then like just hand just
ties him up like nope done uh there's an
awful Crossover with the Punisher with
azreel Batman and and and Punisher and
Punisher beats that Batman well anybody
can beat AEL Batman it's an awful book
by the way don't even waste your time I
yeah go look for it I I'll give you my
copy
I'm I'm going to Jersey just to pick
that up yeah come on by I'll give you a
whole bunch of copies of [__] I I'll
give you my uh my uh I don't
remember full of shitty Comics I I lit
you can have all my gen
13s in that case man in that case I be
13 again yeah so I hope you guys are
ready on once I finish up with with
Marvel MH uh in in kind of catching up
or at least getting a general idea of
what's going on in the Marvel universe
so far I'm going to switch over to DC
and then I'm going to have a lot of
conversations and questions for Benny on
the podcast too and Rob just you guys
talk about Marvel what's in my
email I love I love learning about DC
because I don't really know anything
about DC so when you guys are like
Superman is so strong that he's singing
to people I'm like all right like I can
literally see Superman standing on the
edge of a mountain singing like Frank
sinra yeah singing his heart people he's
got like a little karaoke box like
singing to people singing to the
world I'm planning on starting with like
the at the the point where they reset it
so I'm
hoping to not like go too far back
because it's impossible to collect no
just start with the new 52 that's I
that's what they want you to do yeah
it's only they do a new crisis that's
all you need to do yeah I mean like I
mean it's like like Benny explained on
comic story and with Marvel Now like
like there's like 60 years where the
comics and so Marvel's just like forget
all the stuff that you've read so far
Marvel Now start with issue number one
of everything did you guys see like just
really quick aside the Daredevil or the
Daredevil the DC thing um did you uh I I
assume you guys are in in in any way
familiar with that scene from I think
it's Justice League back when like Guy
Gardner was on the team and Batman was
in charge of it but everybody was lame
and Batman punched and and uh guy and
Batman punched guy
Garder no I didn't see that one who's
guy Garder oh one of the green laners
don't worry about a Sal it's over here
oh
okay Guy Gardner is sure the chat's like
oh my God Rob really yeah guy Gardner's
a was a Green Lantern it was like they
were doesn't matter uh he's a he was a
douche okay and he was just like why is
Batman like here like he's just being a
douche and then Batman just enough
punches him in the face he's out with
one punch guy Gardner has been rasling
and ab and annoying the Justice League
forever Batman shows up and goes like
what is why haven't any of you just
punched this guy in the
face um it was old old story uh from
like the 80s I think and it's an amazing
moment everyone loves it they've made
countless references to it there's an
there's a there's a reference in uh the
cartoon Batman Brave and the Bold where
uh where Batman punches guy Garder he
goes out in one punch and and like blue
bead and Booster Gold are just like oh
one punch oh my God Martian Man misses
the fight he's like what happened oh
that punched Batman in the face he goes
oh I missed it like that sucks I really
want to see
that um yeah as matter fact on the Young
Justice they talk about bringing new
members into the Justice League yeah and
they say Guy Gardner yeah you got just
you got John Stewart and you got Hal
Jordan sitting there and they're like
how about this guy Gardner guy heard
he's got a green lter there like no yeah
Jordan and Batman
no um but there's uh but anyway it's a
classic like moment from the Justice
League stories and with the new 52 we
know Guy Gardner is a Redland Ln and he
and Batman are working together and uh
Batman says or and Guy Gard is like you
know I I would kick your ass if I could
or if if I had the time and Batman's
like I think it' probably take about one
punch and Guy Garner says not in this
universe and you're like oh and you're
like it didn't happen in the new
52 like
oh that's too bad I'm sad that's like
that that hit me I was like oh real Qui
this in there because this is the more
recent uh discussions I guess the rumors
going around about the new 52 and the
new crisis that's supposedly going to be
happening yes um because we are running
a little longer here so we need to start
kind of winding down Fair okay I want
the opinions of especially from Rob and
Dave because they don't know much about
Marvel and I me DC and you the rumor is
now New 52 as of April when this whole
future send thing comes to a close and
we find out about the Multiverse being
in multiversity which is the story that
starts up in August okay is all going to
reveal that the new 52 is pretty much
like another one of the Earths and we're
going to go back to the the primary
continuity that would be so great that
sounds that sounds like a smart idea
because they're they're going to treat
New 52 like the Ultimate Universe oh
that see like from what has been
explained to me like there were just too
many inconsistencies like they came
along and they said we want to reboot
the entire DC Universe so that people
that don't know anything about previous
Comics can basically pick up and start
reading well it's like uh we we just
reviewed flasho for the upcoming Bo back
issues and I think flasho was supposed
to be just a flash story and then DC
editorial said oh we can reboot
everything now and they shoehorned it in
so I don't even think that like so the
new 52 had was an
afterthought yeah so I feel like hold on
hold on I'm still here I turned off the
camera for a minute because the wife
came be here but she's not like dressed
to be on camera but she's going to her
chair and everything and then that's
okay just I'm just adjusting my room to
make things yeah oh okay but yeah it's
not like Tiffany where she was like
fully like I'm going out right now she's
leaving but uh like I just woke up I
yeah don't film me yeah
exactly um but we are coming to the end
of the podcast anyway so that's what I'm
kinding fair enough okay so yeah I think
like they didn't have a plan and then
they just gave yeah the new 52 I think
was an afterthought and then it was just
and then they' just been doing catch up
and damage control ever since yeah no
and I I agree with you um one of the
biggest things that I'm getting because
of that is in Final prices I open it by
stating uh this may not be in consun
anymore because we're at the new 5 2
yeah and the number one response I get
is Batman refers to him dying in his
books and I have to keep telling people
yes because Batman and Green Lantern
didn't reboot yes because Grant Morrison
said no right so Batman still went
through final crisis but Superman didn't
you know the blackest KN to put zombies
all over the planet Earth but no one
seems to remember that fact never mind
of fact it wouldn't really work in
continuity CU things like green arrow uh
discussing with his entire family all
the things he's done wrong and the new
Green Arrow is like 23 and straight out
of the TV show so I I don't really mind
them going back and kind of you know I
guess I'd call it backpedaling but not
really and saying the new 52 is just a
like an ultimate version of the universe
or like an alternate to the traditional
Comics because I I collected a huge
catalog of Batman stuff that I really
enjoyed and I'm like half of that stuff
didn't happen yeah really well the
Batman stuff seems to have happened the
Batman stuff can still happen by the way
because here here's here's what they did
um the excuse was everything that that
they wanted to keep in continuity this
is what they're stating everything that
they want to keep in continuity happened
in the first five years right that's
that's what they're stating okay now the
problem with that is that works for
things like Superman where they're like
okay well he got killed by doomsday but
he came back and that's pretty much the
only significant thing that seems to
Happ in a
yeah you know we've got uh situations
where um what's it called uh like
Supergirl she came to the planet Earth
and none of her continuity happened
right so we just reboot her um Batgirl
apparently paralyzed but she recovered
but they have things like it's like
Batman has had four Robins yep that
doesn't work in five years was it four
or was it five it was five it was uh
dick Jason Tim Damian yeah four yeah
four because Stephanie Brown didn't
count and they just the entire emotional
Spectrum situation with the with the
lantern the sinestra war and all that
stuff seems to have happened that no way
that could have happened in five years
did blackest Knight happen blackest KN
okay if you read the normal continuity
it doesn't seem to ever get brought up
if you read the the the lantern
continuity it's all right there because
it can't it could happened because the
entire world was turned into zombies I
mean because would you would you
recommend me picking up a Brightest Day
Omnibus that's coming out next month no
no no no no avoid avoid brightest day
even if you read black night start black
night and then don't and then okay here
just a quick I am actually going to do
Blackest Night in like a couple a couple
of months uh a couple weeks um I'm going
to cover that and then go bright to day
Blackest Night is the cool story and
what happens the the resolution of the
entire thing is we discover that there's
also because the black ring is what is
discovered under that but we also
discover that there is a white ring
which is life yeah at the end of the
blackest Knight to defeat the black
rings the white light chooses like
Champions to be the white bearers and
they kill it well after that's done the
white rings are still around and they
have to and Brightest Day is following a
bunch of obscure DC heroes like they
love to do in these the you know the
the2 weekly um even the Futures End
event they like to pick obscure
superheroes and try to make a story
around them that's what Brightest Day is
Brightest Day is a continuation for
Deadman Hawkman Hawk Girl Swamp Thing no
one you care about no and I don't think
it even South can vouch but I don't
think it even has anything to do with
the majority of the continuity it's just
what these nine people are doing
basically Pages how did they I don't
even know at the end of the like the the
rest of the lanterns don't even fully
acknowledge that the white light is even
there do it like you would think that
like how Jordan be like maybe I should
follow dead man as the White Lantern and
see what's going on here because yeah no
it's weird it is weird it's it's it was
like it was like the book end to the
entire event but it doesn't follow
anything that happened out of the event
it's no it's more like a nice PS like
seeing every like everybody come back I
lost sound from South did you guys lose
sound from South no I didn't I just lost
you guys oh did we all go away no I can
hear you fine oh oh that was weird okay
I'm back I didn't lose anybody I was
just like what's going on no it was my
headset okay uh like that black uh
Brightest Day is a nice cute PS to the
end of it
oh what oh it says there's a problem
with the call and it's trying to get it
back but I don't know what that
means huh oh with uh looks like Benny
lost yeah I lost Benny and Dave oops
sorry everybody well anyway all right so
go ahead oh uh let me see if I can call
them back really quick okay I don't know
how to do that wait well anyway the uh
oh there we go hey
everybody
um we're still waiting on Benny I think
but
yeah Dave are you
there nope oh well
we need to start wrapping this up anyway
technology Sor every technological
advancements yeah there you guys are hey
there we go all right we're just waiting
on Benny but in the meantime oh nope all
right let's all right anyway uh look you
know hopefully the
uh the uh let me just end it and then
call him back end it call him back see
what happens okay um there we go all
right sorry about that that was weird
yeah I don't know what happened oh did
did we all lose or it was just me it was
it was no it was everybody except for
Rob yeah just Okay cool so I'm not crazy
then no that was my fault um so yeah uh
black is Knight's cool I'm I really
really hope that you're black is KN got
me back into Comics I read Comics as a
kid I read it up until the Spider-Man
clone saga and at that point in the late
90s I'm like this is just I'm a kid I
don't have money for all of this and
this is just getting stupid yeah and I
left and while I was deployed to
Afghanistan I was really getting back
into comic books and I bought I bought
the Blackest Night in all the prequels
and I read all the way through it and
I'm like this is kickass and then I saw
the announcement for new52 and I'm like
it's time it's time to return yep yeah I
I've heard the New 52 Green Lantern is
really
good it's it should be too different
from the old 52 Green Lantern yeah he's
the same so um yeah but I hope you're
right man I I really really want that I
I might actually pick up DC again if it
if it fixes everything well supposedly
for this is the rumor mill but we're
going to keep New 52 as an Ultimate
Universe and we just going to condense
the books down to ones that matter and
we're gonna get our our normal
continuity back our original continuity
back yeah see like I would love because
all honest to abandon to abandon the new
52 at this point would be [__] you
pulled so many people in because of it
yeah but if you make it ultimate then it
then it makes sense yeah but um no I'd
love to read DC Comics but the problem
is just like all my time is swept up in
Marvel yeah yeah like I know I I run
into the same problem I only get select
Marvel books that everyone recommends
and I get mostly DC but even my DC like
I still have not read these and they've
been here almost a month now I think the
the super because I I haven't read 32
and I just got 33 which means I've gone
at least a month without reading it yet
wow wow but yeah so I I really tried
like I I tried to pick up a couple of
the new 52 books when I started like you
know preparing for you guys and the
podcast and everything and like I picked
up a ton of Marvel books and I was like
I don't have time for both I can't
possibly keep track my best
recommendation is if you're going to
pick you pick your side you read that
side and then you pick the core books to
the other side yeah yeah I don't read
all DC but I do read Batman and uh you
gota read Batman you gota read Justice
League The Core book not the not the
spinoff ones just just read the core you
know and then if you're going to read
Green Lantern you least need to read
just Green Lantern forget about all the
spin-off crap yeah yeah okay so as we
wind this podcast to a close what's
everybody got going on for the next
little while or so because after
Guardians more Guardians of the Galaxy
month I've got okay I've got the issues
one through three explanation going live
today with a little bit of a a little
bit of a a work work in with s over here
it's not quite as you taking over the
channel for an episode because Sal's
episodes are 30 minutes in themselves
and I do keep to my time constraints but
we do have a little bit of fun back and
forth um and then tomorrow I'm putting
up draxx and then I'm taking a break
because I've been doing this all week
I'm going to take a couple of days but
just a couple of days not like the last
monthong one right but I'm gonna come
back with Angela on the Angela Story
Volume Two and I'm thinking about coming
out with uh someone requested oh the
Batman Thousand Lives video about that
yeah coming back to life and all that
stuff yeah yeah oh and I'm gonna explain
the speed force soon so oh cool which by
the way I don't know real quick real
quick has anybody seen the pie chart for
the Multiverse yes from multi University
the speed force is apparently outside of
all of that yeah makes sense it's got to
be because otherwise how would you be
able to get to all those places right um
so Rob what do you have coming up uh
Howard the
Duck that would be awesome I will watch
that I'm doing Howard the Duck on
Thursday this coming Thursday and then
after that we'll start getting into
Chris clar moner run of the X-Men so Gan
gray uh both sagas of the Phoenix Force
where she becomes Phoenix and the dark
Phoenix force uh William Striker and
then whatever else I feel like doing uh
we might even just go into like a
general discussion about the hellfire
club which is a really really cool group
in Marvel Emma Frost yeah basically yeah
we might we might even do a video fire
club that that's where she started
before she started bumping nasties
Cyclops yeah pretty much man pretty much
but uh yeah and then after that I mean
we've like I mean after Guardians of the
Galaxy like we've got like a year guys
to do um pretty anybody until Ant-Man
comes around I'll be doing Ant-Man about
a month before the movie comes out but
we've got almost a year before that
happens so like we'll have a we'll have
a ton of so Rob's gonna be in trouble
but don't worry DC's got a bunch of crap
to talk about true that's why I'm gonna
switch
over Dave Dave jumps on whatever
bandwagon is going
strong and then s what do you have going
on uh I have just the usual shows of uh
back issues I think uh this week it's
Guardians of the Galaxy you can check it
out right now on TV Little House on
YouTube um that's on back issues uh then
next week's back issues is going to be
flasho because we had to shoot both
episodes back to back so we we're doing
a flasho episode I want to see what I
want to see Ethan Ben think of that Ben
hates
It spoilers Ben doesn't give us an inch
on flasho no he just is like [__] this
he's like
no everything's wrong I haven't even
edited it yet it's uh it'll be crazy uh
is Ethan just like analyzing it the
whole time's like it's funny because
Ethan's usually he's the guy who is like
well does Groot respect the conservation
of mass when he gets bigger does he get
lighter because he's using the mass to
get bigger but when it comes to the time
travel stuff Ben's like well wait if
flash saves his own mom then he doesn't
become Flash so why does the reverse
flash even have a a role to play in this
story and Ethan's like well you know
it's like Terminator like who cares and
Ben's like no I care this is insane you
know why that is right did you explain
it to him why reverse flash EX ex this
well because he's created by The Flash
and he's for the future and he comes
back to the past and he's stuck there so
like no no they they get the reason is
when flash changed time reverse flash
was going through the time stream at the
time so since everything got changed and
he wasn't in a time period right we we
basically we basically say that he is
outside of time right yeah yeah but but
that makes okay I not that when you were
doing your Superman versus The Flash
video and you were like you are so far
off
so yeah I know everybody's been really
patient with me to make another video
finally that's what he's been waiting
for he's been waiting for us all to get
out of the way so he can he pretty
much but I'm not going to be able to for
like another week and a half I'm GNA be
in this cast I'm going to be limited to
either the bed or the couch and having
my foot raised every 15 minutes so
editing for 15 minutes and then stopping
for two hours and then editing for 15
minutes and then stopping for two hours
I'm just I'm going to rename us I'm
going to rename the group we are the you
the YouTube comic book Alliance and
friend Dave is the grippy and cat boy
he's our gripper wait that sounds wrong
in
this but um
yeah of the group I promise I've got a
lot of great things planned I'm planning
on doing after I get out of this damn
cast I'm going to do the rest of Civil
War I'm going to finish that up very
quickly uh and then I'm going to
hopefully go into collecting House of
M and then hopefully Wander over and do
some DC stuff by
then and hopefully while I'm doing the
DC stuff do some indie stuff cool Dave
I'm gonna say this with all like actual
honesty for a second slow down if you're
coming back
finally don't plan nine videos yeah oh
no no no it's going to be like it's
going to be like the the finishing up of
the hard covers is going to happen over
like a period of two weeks okay the way
you like please do not just fledge your
channel in within a week with like nine
videos the House of M is probably gonna
be one
week and then I'm going to do but I have
all this planned because I've had a lot
of time to plan it's true in my
head and I get ahead of myself in my
head well in your head you're also drug
so be careful yeah yeah I mean doing the
house of him over the course of a week
is a good call because you can do about
like one video a day it's three it's
three hard covers oh okay so I mean if I
if I do three videos in one week I've
got it covered okay yeah that sounds
good enough because I don't go in depth
into the story like you I just tell
people to buy
stuff
basically way to collect it yeah good
stuff all right well um I guess we're
going to call it a night I don't what
time is it right now I don't even know
what time it is it's so right now we're
all looking at and we're debating this
is going to happen but pay attention to
Rob's Channel because we're going to see
if we can angle it so that we all get on
after the Guardians of the Galaxy we're
all going to see it pretty much about
the same time yeah so we we're all going
to see it within an hour of each other
roughly yeah so we're going to try to
get on and do like a 20 to 30 minute
what did you guys think oh my God it's
amazing oh my God I'm so drunk yeah yeah
yeah so all right well uh yeah so um I
guess maybe we'll catch you guys later
on tonight so yeah have a good one
everyone and we'll see you next time
right here at the weekly poll AKA Marvel
explain AKA comic story AKA TV AKA
whatever the hell Dave's doing all right
we'll catch you guys later he's Groot
see
you I am Groot